foi tudo bom
de pronto assim o que faz da vida
essa é uma pergunta que me inquieta pelo
menos 17 anos ela geralmente volta a
aparecer toda vez que eu conheço alguém
e por mais que essa possa ser uma
resposta simples para quem já sabe o que
quer da vida
desde criancinha pra mim essa nunca foi
uma resposta simples
não é à toa que eu fiz duas graduações
como estava falou administração e
relações públicas
e nesse vai e volta entre os dois cursos
eu realmente não me sentia 100 por cento
pertencente a um grupo ou outro
hoje eu percebo que na realidade eu
estava bem assado
eu sempre fui uma pessoa de conexões
só que quando a gente começa na
profissão a gente não tem ideia disso o
mundo pede respostas rápidas e eu tinha
um plano
eu literalmente fiz um plano de carreira
para ser bem sucedida e me desenvolver
na carreira ser competitiva no mercado
e nesse nesse percurso de 2001 quando eu
comecei os cursos até mais ou menos 2007
quando estava terminando o primeiro
deles
eu até fui acho super bem sucedido no
cumprimento do plano que eu tinha
desenhado nos graduações experiência
prática de experimentação varejo e
serviços na indústria em intercâmbio no
exterior
fluente em inglês preparada para no
final da graduação entre um desses
cursos desses programas de trainee e
logo seu executivo está criado e sá
com uma carreira global esse é o meu
plano
eu cumpri ele e ele não fazia o menor
sentido pra mim
em 2007 quando me dei conta disso eu
simplesmente precisei para
para para encontrar as minhas próprias
respostas que muitas vezes não vem nos
manuais vocacionais que a gente
geralmente estuda e nessa trajetória eu
tinha uma certeza eu precisava procurar
silva
ela foi minha primeira chefe ela me
contou com 17 anos numa grande empresa
de varejo aqui do sul e o que lembrava é
que o tempo que eu trabalhei com ela foi
a fase da vida onde eu mais crescer como
pessoa sendo profissional e eu estava
certo
eu encontrei a sílvio e trabalhando com
ela aos pouquinhos retomando o ritmo na
consultoria que ela tinha na época
atuando em comunicação interna e
recursos humanos
eu descobri a educadora e hoje a silvia
meu sócio ea gente tem uma empresa de
educação corporativa
mas não pensem que a história termina
por aí porque estava muito curto a
palestra rápida mas nem tanto né
muitas emoções ainda vieram pela frente
especialmente porque nesse mundo dos
cursos de aprendizagem a gente também
está sempre aprendendo e sempre se
desenvolvendo e foi um grupo de estudos
do ano passado que eu encontrei ainda
novas respostas sobre mim mesma
o tema do grupo era educação a gente em
agosto do ano passado estava debatendo e
discutindo muitas coisas sobre o futuro
da educação sobre práticas a gente pode
trazer para nossa vida como que a gente
pode avançar e reinventar o que a gente
faz no dia-a-dia hoje e esse foi o
primeiro esquema que eu desenhei a gente
nesse encontro do dia 10 de agosto de
a gente assistiu ted do que a europa em
som ea gente queria conversar sobre isso
ea gente assistiu o vídeo nós éramos
mais ou menos uma 78 pessoas
a gente assistiu o vídeo eu fiquei
encantada por tudo aquilo
quando a conversa começou eu fui direto
do cavalete desenha esse esquema chamei
o pessoal e disse gente olha só o que
vocês acham que isso aqui o que eu
entendi o que ele disse é isso pra cá e
isso e assim ele conclui assim faz
sentido quando eu olhei para as pessoas
me pergunta isso elas me olhavam de um
jeito que eu nunca tinha visto
aí eu pensei
aí tem alguma coisa e eu quero descobrir
e foi rápido mas eu ficava leite fez
história por que na mesma semana eu tive
uma reunião com bruno ramos que é uma
das pessoas que fazem esse evento aqui
acontecendo
ela estava na reunião comigo daqui a
pouco ela olhou para o painel disse
lauryn desenho e foi seguindo a conversa
e ela me observa e deu aquela respirada
fundo e me disse isso no sedex unisinos
que olhei naquela hora eu pensei atenção
naquela hora eu olhei para ela e como
assim ao vivo
assim na hora que aconteceu uma coisa
diferente ali porque ao invés de dar
aquela tensão que eu tinha conhecido
sete anos atrás veio uma empolgação e da
empolgação de um sim eu digo sim claro
faria
vocês imaginam é que foi a bruno sair da
substantiva que eu entrei em desespero
porque não tinha ideia como dois meses e
meio depois eu ia fazer aquilo
tem muita gente que trabalha com
facilitação gráfica que o nome desse
tipo de técnica e profissionalmente eu
fazia de brincadeira nas minhas aulas
tem gente que tá acostumado a fazer
prospecção de conteúdo ao vivo
eu nunca tinha feito no dia 31 de
outubro de 2013
eu estava lá no bourbon country tomada
de coragem desenhando ao vivo 17
palestras do início ao fim da tarde sem
nunca antes ter feito isso na vida
aquelas pessoas mais ortodoxas que jamie
desengana vá nesse meu percurso
profissional como aquela que o trabalho
autônomo consultoria de negócio pj que
não tenha tse férias remuneradas
essas pessoas mais ortodoxos que me
julgava pela trajetória que já tinha já
estava aprendendo até ali chegaram à
conclusão que realmente eu não tinha
jeito era uma perdida porque agora aos
30 anos a obra começou a desenhar
aí eu digo bom
isso rendeu muitas piadas mas também
rendeu outras repercussões
logo depois do texas disse no ano
passado eu comecei a levar mais a sério
essa história de design de informações e
comecei a fazer isso no meu dia a dia
esse hobby divertido isso tudo me trazia
tentou gação ele terá de fazer no
informal acaba virando um negócio acabou
virando um produto serviço e coisa séria
o que é uma coisa estranha para mim
porque como é que pode
é divertido trabalhar não é pesado
eu gosto disso me divirto trabalhando
como é isso tem valor eu ganho por isso
estranho essa sensação toma conta de mim
e o que eu morria de medo era que alguém
me perguntasse onde é que eu tinha
aprendido isso
isso aconteceu a primeira pessoa que me
perguntou como foi gustavo borba
esse cara que vocês viram aqui ou se do
nosso evento
no início desse ano de 2014 quando já
tinha ingressado no mestrado em design
estratégico da unisinos
ele me convidou para fazer parte de um
workshop estava recém começando o meu
papel era literalmente acompanhar o
evento e fazer as conexões e gerar um
painel que representasse o que tinha
acontecido naquele dia
no final do dia ele foi lá comigo
resultado depois que todo mundo já tinha
ido embora e me fez a pergunta
eu olhei pra ele digo a gustavo
eu aprendi isso na vida ele para obras
em curso do processo e eu respondi
administração e relações públicas
eu respirei fundo e diz pra ele e digo
um é gustavo na real e objetiva
essa é uma capacidade que eu desenvolvi
como estratégia como jeito que eu dei na
vida
para driblar os meus principais desafios
da aprendizagem
ele ficou me olhando não perguntou muito
mas acho que tocou ele português nunca
foi meu melhor amigo
aprender a ler e escrever foi bem duro
sabe quando as letras que atrapalham o p
b
o que parece igual e troca as letras
isso acontece comigo até hoje um outro
grau obviamente mas isso foi um baita
desafio é alto na sala de aula era um
drama
eu confesso para vocês só pra vocês
para quem está assistindo à internet que
a primeira vez que eu li um livro do
início ao fim foi no ano passado por
prazer e por opção
eu de outro jeito de aprender na vida e
eu confesso a vocês que a gente encontra
a gente encontra o nosso jeitinho de
avançar e aprende na escola quando na 7ª
série de uma aluna mediana eu
conseguiria uma baita virada
quando eu comecei a fazer um contrato
comigo mesmo e passar a limpo tudo
aquilo que ficava ouvindo
lá e não pensem que essa história de não
conseguir ler é uma coisa de moleza
preguiça porque eu sempre fui inclusive
chamado de cdf na aula porque eu era
daquelas que não gostava que ninguém
falasse nem alto nem conversar se porque
se me atrapalhava isso tinha uma razão
eu precisava escutar o que o professor
falava porque se eu não escutasse e
anastácio de qualquer jeito eu não
aprendi depois sozinha e esses esquemas
eu aprendi lá eu não tinha me dado conta
que isso era uma coisa que tinha valor
dos outros que não diga que não acabaram
desenvolvendo os a não deram essa mesma
brigada que eu dei e depois desse evento
eu comecei a entender mais o que afinal
era um talento que não são aquelas
coisas que vêm numa etiqueta pronto aqui
coloca e identifica fácil mas é uma
coisa mais especial que muitas vezes
acontece na vida nosso cotidiano de todo
dia e com a pressa que a gente vive a
gente acaba passando batido por esses
detalhes
geralmente as outras pessoas acabam até
anotando mais fácil que a gente tem hoje
me dedico bastante isso porque eu
percebo que é bem difícil para as
pessoas trabalhando com comunica com
educação organizacional é bem difícil
quando pergunta isso as pessoas que
fazem a vida quais são seus principais
talentos é difícil descrever é difícil
de dizer mas eu acho que é importante
que a gente tome responsabilidade por
isso porque conhecendo um pouco da gente
mesmo é bem difícil fazer escolhas no
mundo cheio de oportunidades e
possibilidades
só que a gente é o único cada um aprende
um jeito essa história tem tantas outras
aqui que poderiam estar nesse lugar
também o que eu tenho pra dizer pra
vocês hoje é que uma das coisas que eu
acho mais importante é que a gente
assuma a responsabilidade pelo nosso
próprio aprendizado porque sendo únicos
nós somos automaticamente co
responsáveis pelo nosso aprendizado
então
que a gente consiga conjugar melhor essa
liberdade de opções com responsabilidade
e próxima palestra minha estava faltando
o esquema né
então eu trouxe um último slide onde eu
falar onde o conto um pouco do que eu
penso é que por mais que a educação
formal hoje ela seja ainda muito baseada
focada no trabalho baseado em explicação
recheada de recompensas incentivos
encadeados com uma minha senha da
punição pelo erro eu acredito que é
possível a gente fazer os nossos
próprios percurso de descoberta para
validar e reconhecer o que a gente tem
de bom que a gente traz na vida que a
gente tem a oferecer para o mundo num
exercício e de protagonismo da vida e da
realização que a gente quer ter essa pra
mim é a chave para as microevoluções que
a gente fala que podem mudar o mundo pra
mim é cada um assume a responsabilidade
por si mesmo pelo seu próprio
desenvolvimento e deixar de dizer o que
acha que pode ser melhor que começar a
colocar em prática aquilo que está
pronto para fazer diferente cada um seu
tempo e com a sua verdade
por isso a melhor coisa que eu tenho
para fazer hoje é deixar com cada um de
vocês essa pergunta que tanto me
inquieta e aí o que você faz da sua vida
muito obrigado